Steve Kaplan: New skills start to appear in
Melissa McCarthy’s case [SPY movie].
Courage, boldness, everything that she wasn’t
in the Normal World, back in her basement
office at the CIA, that vermin-ridden basement
office.
So you have the Reaction and then there’s
a part of the movie that we call Connections.
Connections is the part of the movie when
your characters start to find unexpected allies
and (sometimes unexpected) enemies.
In TROPIC THUNDER, the two main actors, Robert
Downey, Jr. who is playing an Australian who
is playing a black sergeant in Vietnam is
always at odds with Ben Stiller’s lead actor
and they barely talk to each other.
They don’t get along.
But in the middle part of the movie they start
to actually talk to each other.
It’s the first time that they are actually
trying to make a connection.
Connection is when things slow down in the
movie where you have heart-to-heart conversations.
You tell the truth about each other.
I guess the one thing, the one caveat that
I’d like to put out there is that all these
elements are in all these comedy movies, but
they’re not necessarily in the same order.
After connections and new directions and characters
get what we call the Discovered Goal you have
disconnections which is the dark night of
the soul.
That is usually the part about 3/4 of the
way or 4/5ths of the way through where everything
seems lost and your hero is going to fail
and then somehow they find the power or the
strength one more time and they win.
Now normally that comes at about 3/4s of the
way, 4/5ths of the way through the movie.
In GROUNDHOG DAY, however, that dark night
of the soul comes in at about midway through
it.
It happens after the sequence in which Bill
Murray, who because he’s found the skill
to get whatever he wants by simply being able
to anticipate what’s going to happen because
he’s living the day over and over and over
again, he’s able to rob a truck full of
money, he’s able to sleep with all the women
in town, and then he gets the idea that he
wants to have a relationship Andie MacDowell
(the producer Rita).
Even though he tried over and over again,
it always ends with this great slap montage…slap,
slap, slap.
And now we’re only about half way through
the movie and that’s the time in which he
has lost all hope.
He goes through this great series of suicide
attempts.
They are attempts because he does kill himself
but he wakes up the next day.
In fact, GROUNDHOG DAY is a really interesting
structure.
It’s basically structured after the long
first act in which it sets everything up.
It’s structured like the Five Stages of
Grief of Dr. Elisabeth Kübler-Ross.
There is denial, there is a very short section
of anger, and there’s a long negotiation
period then there is depression, and finally
there is acceptance.
But in GROUNDHOG DAY there is three acts to
acceptance.
There is getting [the character] Rita to believe
in him, that’s an entire act.
Then there is the act of trying to save the
old man in which he’s got to come to grips
with the fact that he’s not God, he’s
simply a man going through an impossible situation.
And finally there is the final act of acceptance
in which he simply accepts his fate.
He is never going to live to see Feburary
3rd.
He is always going to be living in February
2nd and he’s o.k.
with it.
He’s found out that the purpose of life
for him is simply to do as much good as he
can in the one day he has.
So that’s a way in which just understanding
that this framework, this structure isn’t
a cookie cutter form that must be followed.
That all these parts of the journey happen,
they don’t necessarily happen all in the
same order or all at the same time.
The thought that certain things have to happen
on page ten and that certain things have to
happen on page twenty-six is probably not
a really good way to approach writing a screenplay.
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: Can you name another
movie that uses the 5 Stages of Grief by Dr.
Elisabeth Kübler-Ross as it’s story structure?